In the United States, there are 60,000 people
who have a pacemaker that connects to the Internet.
The defibrillators allow a physician at a distance
to give a shock to a heart
in case a patient needs it.
But if you don't need it,
and somebody else gives you the shock,
it's not a good thing.
Of course, we're going to go even deeper than the human body.
We're going down to the cellular level these days.
Up until this point, all the technologies
I've been talking about have been silicon-based, ones and zeroes,
but there's another operating system out there:
the original operating system, DNA.
And to hackers, DNA is just another operating system
waiting to be hacked.
It's a great challenge for them.
There are people already working on hacking the software of life,
and while most of them are doing this to great good
and to help us all,
some won't be.
So how will criminals abuse this?
Well, with synthetic biology you can do some pretty neat things.
For example, I predict that we will move away
from a plant-based narcotics world
to a synthetic one. Why do you need the plants anymore?
You can just take the DNA code from marijuana
or poppies or coca leaves
and cut and past that gene
and put it into yeast,
and you can take those yeast
and make them make the cocaine for you,
or the marijuana, or any other drug.
So how we use yeast in the future
is going to be really interesting.
In fact, we may have some really interesting bread and beer
as we go into this next century.
The cost of sequencing the human genome is dropping precipitously.
It was proceeding at Moore's Law pace,
but then in 2008, something changed.
The technologies got better,
and now DNA sequencing is proceeding at a pace
five times that of Moore's Law.
That has significant implications for us.
It took us 30 years to get from
the introduction of the personal computer
to the level of cybercrime we have today,
but looking at how biology is proceeding so rapidly,
and knowing criminals and terrorists as I do,
we may get there a lot faster
with biocrime in the future.
It will be easy for anybody to go ahead
and print their own bio-virus,
enhanced versions of ebola or anthrax,
weaponized flu.
We recently saw a case where some researchers
made the H5N1 avian influenza virus more potent.
It already has a 70 percent mortality rate
if you get it, but it's hard to get.
Engineers, by moving around a small number
of genetic changes,
were able to weaponize it
and make it much more easy for human beings to catch,
so that not thousands of people would die,
but tens of millions.
You see, you can go ahead and create
new pandemics, and the researchers who did this
were so proud of their accomplishments,
they wanted to publish it openly
so that everybody could see this
and get access to this information.
But it goes deeper than that.
DNA researcher Andrew Hessel
has pointed out quite rightly
that if you can use cancer treatments,
modern cancer treatments,
to go after one cell while leaving all the other cells
around it intact,
then you can also go after any one person's cell.
Personalized cancer treatments
are the flip side of personalized bioweapons,
which means you can attack any one individual,
including all the people in this picture.
How will we protect them in the future?
What to do? What to do about all this?
That's what I get asked all the time.
For those of you who follow me on Twitter,
I will be tweeting out the answer later on today. (Laughter)
Actually, it's a bit more complex than that,
and there are no magic bullets.
I don't have all the answers,
but I know a few things.
In the wake of 9/11,
the best security minds
put together all their innovation
and this is what they created for security.
If you're expecting the people who built this to protect you
from the coming robopocalypse — (Laughter)
— uh, you may want to have a backup plan. (Laughter)
Just saying. Just think about that. (Applause)
Law enforcement is currently a closed system.
It's nation-based, while the threat is international.
Policing doesn't scale globally. At least, it hasn't,
and our current system of guns, border guards, big gates and fences
are outdated in the new world into which we're moving.
So how might we prepare for some of these specific threats,
like attacking a president or a prime minister?
This would be the natural government response,
to hide away all our government leaders
in hermetically sealed bubbles.
But this is not going to work.
The cost of doing a DNA sequence is going to be trivial.
Anybody will have it and we will all have them in the future.
So maybe there's a more radical way that we can look at this.
What happens if we were to take
the President's DNA, or a king or queen's,
and put it out to a group of a few hundred
trusted researchers so they could
study that DNA and do penetration testing against it
as a means of helping our leaders?
Or what if we sent it out to a few thousand?
Or, controversially, and not without its risks,
what happens if we just gave it to the whole public?
Then we could all be engaged in helping.
We've already seen examples of this working well.
The Organized Crime and Corruption Reporting Project
is staffed by journalists and citizens
where they are crowd-sourcing
what dictators and terrorists are doing
with public funds around the world,
and, in a more dramatic case,
we've seen in Mexico,
a country that has been racked
by 50,000 narcotics-related murders
in the past six years.
They're killing so many people
they can't even afford to bury them all
in anything but these unmarked graves
like this one outside of Ciudad Juarez.
What can we do about this? The government has proven ineffective.
So in Mexico, citizens, at great risk to themselves,
are fighting back to build an effective solution.
They're crowd-mapping the activities of the drug dealers.
Whether or not you realize it,
we are at the dawn of a technological arms race,
an arms race between people
who are using technology for good
and those who are using it for ill.
The threat is serious, and the time to prepare for it is now.
I can assure you that the terrorists and criminals are.
My personal belief is that,
rather than having a small, elite force
of highly trained government agents
here to protect us all,
we're much better off
having average and ordinary citizens
approaching this problem as a group
and seeing what we can do.
If we all do our part,
I think we'll be in a much better space.
The tools to change the world
are in everybody's hands.
How we use them is not just up to me,
it's up to all of us.
This was a technology I would frequently deploy
as a police officer.
This technology has become outdated in our current world.
It doesn't scale, it doesn't work globally,
and it surely doesn't work virtually.
We've seen paradigm shifts in crime and terrorism.
They call for a shift to a more open form
and a more participatory form of law enforcement.
So I invite you to join me.
After all, public safety is too important to leave to the professionals.
Thank you. (Applause)
(Applause)